so I have a lot of things I want to talk
to you about but I guess I have to start
with how does it feel to be part of a
movie that's the biggest box office film
of all time yeah you know okay oh God I
mean look very very blessed to be in
something that you know I'm not really
sure we'll ever be repeated ever again
you know to kind of the build up of that
you know of 1890 movies and so that
crescendo finish you know just kind of
everybody was so you know they knew
those characters deeply and they felt
for them deeply as well at the end I'm
amazing
completely jumping into why I get to
talk to you today you've worked with a
number of great filmmakers what is it
about Angley that is similar to those
other filmmakers and how is he different
if at all no I don't really go into the
comparing I just go into the projects
really because I I mean I I think in
terms of Wang style I feel like he's the
he's like a contemplative quiet composer
you know that will just sidle up to you
and just you know will feel the air and
then it'll be a sentence or something
that shifts shifts your change in your
performance which I like Col Joye one of
the things I thought that the high frame
rate in this movie that have you seen
the finished film yeah so for me the 3d
high frame rate was incredible yeah it's
just like it's like looking through a
window instead of a movie screen what
was your takeaway from it when you first
saw it I mean it's I mean it's bonkers
system you know the fact that this is a
like a pioneering movie that I mean when
I first met and you know when we talked
about the project he said look I think
people will be shooting like this in 20
years time I just don't have 20 years
and it's just like well we're really
spearheading with this and the fact that
it's 120 frames per second and watching
it
you know just being immersed by the
colors you know just just obviously just
so much information being fed into you
it's like you are kind of like you know
spherically they're you know and the
sound quality you know production values
and obviously with the three Titans in
broccoli and Smith it's you know it's a
wonderful cocktail to be above one of
the things that I heard was you know the
cameras that he had to use were a little
different some of them I guess were
bigger I'm not a hundred percent on that
but he did mention it took more time to
film because of the technology can you
talk a little bit about working with the
brand new technology and how it was
maybe a little different I guess I can
talk about the the filming with it with
the double well I guess you know let's
say we were in barn in Glenville and
we'd be shooting that sequence with the
body double Victor and you know with the
usual kind of dots that we've been known
to see and shooting that sequence there
and then going into a studio somewhere
in Budapest much later with with the
wetter team and them kind of measuring
it out to scale the barn and I was
watching the footage and we'll switching
roles playing the younger well now and
for us as actors was to replicate our
movements again and keep him as close as
possible yeah um what was it like
reading the script for the first time
because I would imagine you're reading
it and you know it's a younger will are
you at some point thinking are they
gonna be able to pull this off this is
incredible stuff totally yeah I just
think yeah how are they gonna do this
and yeah you know I remember when I was
watching in Utah I was just you know I
was there just enjoying the story and
watching the film but constantly just
shaking my head at these interactions
with the older and the younger self just
how can this how can this be possible
you know you know the physical touching
of it as well you know is it's just
pretty extraordinary I would imagine
that getting to work with what you've
worked with a lot of cool people but
getting to work with Will Smith had to
have been awesome did you find more
people wanted to visit you on this set
then maybe some of the others uh no no
no no I quickly closed that all off you
know yeah yeah because that happens well
I would imagine but no what was it like
working with him because I've heard he's
such a giving and generous person yeah
yeah I mean that is that is who is he is
who he is and generosity of spirit that
you know the you know how the amount of
food cooks and you know the the
continuity could have changed very very
easily you know I mean that their
dinners everywhere parties everywhere
just though you know and just a you know
I love the energy in an example to all
leading actors out there on these big
movies I definitely have to touch on I
haven't seen the whole thing yet but the
Dark Crystal oh yeah they don't say no
yeah yeah it's it's unbelievable the
puppetry and what Netflix did with that
thing what was it what did it mean to be
a part of that project oh I mean it was
some fantastic I mean I mean you know I
always remember watching that a while
back but to you know being the sessions
I was wondering how they were gonna do
it I mean it was like for our each
session there was a four hour session
and it was 11 sessions you know mainly I
had just four large pictures of water
early and just constant trips to the
toilet because they're just enable to
get this voice for the Skeksis so yeah
but it's from what I've seen of the
footage it looks amazing
yeah it's unbelievable yeah you know um
I definitely have to touch on the fact
that I am a huge fan of obviously the
Marvel movies I think that the title
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness might be the coolest title
they've done you know um what have you
heard anything from Scott about when you
might be filming have you heard anything
no I you know I did tweet Scott just to
kind of confirm am I in this and they
said yes
yep so yeah that's that's that's good to
know so we'll wait and see what happens
are you did you how early on did you
know that that was happening or did you
find out the day that they announced
that title and everything I didn't know
the title but I hadn't I had a few
little Inklings yeah um I I I'm so
excited for that tanks phone yeah
one of the other things you have coming
up which again another thing I can't
wait to see is lady in the [ __ ] oh yeah
that is an E Plus thing I've realized
you just put your hands and everything
you know Disney Plus every colony yeah
yeah what can you tease about lady in
the [ __ ] uh not a lot I mean I've just
again it's just these I've been doing a
lot of these kind of vocal sessions and
yeah I just kind of just throw
everything at it you know they just
allow you to let rip and improvise a
little bit and your character is apply
the Bulldog yeah yeah so I mean if very
much she's got you jobs are like I've
been working with it so no no kind of I
mean I guess I guess I'm one method that
clearly I was gonna say I'm like does
that hurt after a while uh no there's a
lot of slobber yeah I can understand
wanna kind of yeah
I'm changing a lot of t-shirts right
that's great um listen I wish you
nothing but the best part of this and
have a fantastic day thank you